So I've got the website open and I've
opened dev tools to the Network tab.
I've hit refresh and
all of the network requests are showing.
Here's one image and here's the other.
Notice that their size
definitely isn't the same.
One is 123 kilobytes while
the other is only 63 kilobytes.
It looks like udacity_large has
different dimensions than udacity_small.
$0 refers to whatever
element you have selected,
up in the Elements pane, which,
in this case, is the image.
When you do .naturalWidth on the image,
you see that its original
width is 601 pixels.
Now, I want to take a look
at the other image.
Running the same command
gives us 1202 pixels.
So large is twice as big as small.
The thing is though that
both of these images look,
well, pretty much identical.
So there's a lot of wasted bytes when
you deliver an image with dimensions
that are just too large.
Well yes, some high dpi displays do
need images that have larger dimensions
than what's displayed, that's going to
be a topic later on in this course.
For now, just remember that
images only need to be as large
as they will be displayed.
And what happens to
your users on mobile?
In devtools,
I've set network throttling to 3G,
so I want to see what it's like for
somebody on a bad connection.
Let's refresh and watch.
Ooh.
Notice how the image on the right
took a little bit longer to show up?
That's just unnecessary.
On a mobile device with limited
connectivity, it's a big problem.